do you guys remember when Chris Brown
and Rihanna were in that incident a
couple years ago yeah yeah I've been
watching about that recently to be fair
but just updating myself on it why do
you think there was a public outcry for
Chris Brown and Rihanna to the point
that he was canceled for a while and
couldn't do shows but there was no
public outcry for cardi B when she
publicly admitted and robbing men I
think because Chris Brown's a guy so
everyone looks at the guys like the
person who beat someone up is not good
but for a girl if you do that you don't
get the same but I feel like the thing
is obviously don't get me wrong you
shouldn't hurt or hit someone but you
don't know the underlying issues it's
all talk at the end of the day in it do
you think if a woman hits first that the
men should have the right to hit back
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
because girls get away with it I hate to
say it but that is how it is like girls
have the perception of like little Miss
innocent like they don't do nothing bad
like it's okay for a girl to smack a boy
around the face like in an argument but
if a boy did the same to you like
imagine a boy Smite you around the face
like you'd be fuming and like it would
be a soul so like why is it not the same
vice versa I'm awful if all right equal
life I mean yeah I guess like if a boy
slaps you and you slap a boy you're just
as bad as each other do you think that
men should have a right to hit women if
they if the woman hits first yeah fair
play like if I know that if I I mean I'm
not condoning it at all but like like I
said like you're just as bad as each
other like if you smack a boy and then a
boy smacks you back you kind of can't be
mad about it because you have to admit
that you were in the wrong in the first
place would you say it's not good either
way do you say they're not just as bad
as each other like wouldn't the woman be
worse and he would be acting in
self-defense it's a tricky one because
men are technically stronger than women
so if you give them a little smack
around the face and he boots you in the
jaw like that's not that's not the same
like so I have a question if um my
producer blessing that's his name right
there goes up to Dwayne The Rock Johnson
and hits him and Dwayne The Rock Johnson
smacks him back is are they equally in
the wrong would you say that's the same
thing I would have to say yes because I
think the same like Sable goes but like
but in the same like The Rock will have
a harder smack so do you think people
would feel bad for him though 100 100 I
wouldn't want to get smacked by The Rock
if he hit the rock first you don't think
it's dumb on him everyone pretty hate on
him and be like you're you're an idiot
like why are you doing that the only
point I'm making is that it's
interesting because it's different when
it's a man and a woman you know what
though like that is the perception that
like men that women are allowed to get
away with it men on but I genuinely
believe like if you smack a boy you have
to expect to smack back like not expect
it but like you can't be mad if it
happens you have to own up to your own
like you can't just be mad at someone
for doing the same thing you've done
you're a hypocrite then and who wants to
be a hypocrite or why do you think there
was such a public outcry with Rihanna
and Chris Brown but there was not the
same outcry for cardi B when she
publicly admitted to drinking and
robbing men no that is [__] up because
cardi B that's so wrong like on like
there shouldn't there should have been
like the same operation he wasn't
canceled at all no she should have been
she should have been because that's
disgusting what she done I think for
some reason it's still if a man does
anything to a woman it's bad but if a
woman does anything to a man it's still
somehow the man's fault just depends
like situation and how the media show
everything you don't know what's real if
a woman hits a man first then a man
should be able to defend himself yeah
definitely it works both ways like
shouldn't be no hitting as toxic sort of
that do you think if a woman hits
someone she should expect to get hit
back I'm not here for violence against
women like
and you can contain yourself and you
know I mean control the situation you
should contact me a knife then I've got
to do what I need to do to protect my
life honestly I have to do whatever that
needs you know I mean whatever needs a
must you know I mean I'm gonna do that I
have a question if my producer at their
blessing goes up to Dwayne The Rock
Johnson and hits him can Dwayne The Rock
Johnson hit him back absolutely because
you hit him I'm provoked so wouldn't you
say that's a little bit of a double
standard you have then for men and for
women because madagas
that's a weaker Man versus a man that's
clearly stronger an offense black woman
against women you know what I mean it's
too fat it's too fat you know what I
mean how is it fair when Dwayne The Rock
Johnson is much stronger than him and
because Dwayne Johnson put in the
[__] work and he put himself to that
size in it so if he happens has that
size in that shrimp that's his business
you know I mean but I think man against
man is always going to be fair I'm gonna
get someone's gonna be fair man against
woman not so fast so you do think you
think Chris Brown was wrong for hitting
Rihanna even if she hit first I'm not
gonna comment on that because
what kind of question is
I wasn't there I wasn't there in it so
like I don't know what happened between
them I don't know who hit first but
we're glad Breezy's back do do you think
why do you think that Chris Brown was
canceled for the Rihanna situation but
but cardi B wasn't when she publicly
admitted to drinking and robbing men do
you think there's a bit of a double
standard yeah 100 shouldn't have done
that but he also shouldn't have used his
Force against her he's
big now but I'm saying cardi B never
left like he had he had to go away for a
couple years
um
which ain't been physically violent and
taken men's money like what if reverse
if a guy was drugging and robbing women
not touching them just drugging them
yeah
it's not a standard right yeah it is but
in the same breath there's a difference
between I personally believe like a
woman you know isn't as strong as a man
why do you think that
so many people canceled Chris Brown
after like the Rihanna incident but they
didn't cancel cardi B when she was
publicly talking about drinking and
robbing men that's a good question
actually I really don't have answer for
that it's interesting though right I
didn't even think about that do you know
what I love Rihanna down to like that's
my girl but like I think they squashed
it so why should I beef him why do you
think there was a public outcry for the
Chris Brown and Rihanna situation
however there was not the same outcry
when cardi B publicly admitted to
drinking and robbing men a lot of things
that happen to women are predominantly
done by men so obviously like we're all
target men for things that they do
obviously also we're very scared like
because we see a man we want to run but
obviously with cardi B in that like we
are like kind of we're kind of like
saying oh that's girl power yeah do that
to them and honestly I don't agree
though did you know men are more likely
to be victims of a violent crime really
I did not know that wow when you think
about it we talk about women walking
home alone at night men can't walk home
alone at night either but if me and you
walk home and we get attacked and we
scream a guy might come help us who's
helping another guy that is so cheap I
didn't see it right yeah that's actually
very true that's sad actually do you
think that if we hit a guy that he
should have the right to hit back
absolutely I believe in equal for that
because if I'm hitting you I'm expecting
it absolutely yeah why you hate men okay
okay so do you guys remember the the
Chris Brown and Rihanna situation
you'd let him beat you oh yeah yeah over
those two sides to every story but what
do you think happened I think they had a
fight I think she's just as Rowdy as he
is and that's that do you think if a
woman hits a man she should expect to
get hit back definitely and I'll tell my
son the same thing if a woman hits you
once walk away she hits you twice you
hit her back why do you think that there
was a public outcry for Chris Brown and
Rihanna however there was no public
outcry when cardi B publicly admitted to
drinking and robbing men it's corruption
they post what they want you to see I
think there's a double standard in
society when it comes to believing men
and believing women absolutely why was
Chris Brown canceled for the Rihanna
situation but cardi B publicly admitted
to cheating and robbing men and face
seemingly no career no repercussions I
would like to know this that monster I
don't know if you say like time and
airlock between like 2008 when it
happened on like 2008 to 19 when cardi B
is doing a thing like a lot of things
have changed like standards and that
kind of drops a lot so that's why she
probably got away with it why do you
think that Chris Brown was canceled for
his situation with Rihanna yet cardi B
faced seemingly no repercussions for
publicly admitting to and robbing men
because either man and a black man so
because she's a woman and women women
get away more than men why do you think
that is because the world is sexist why
do you think that's fair no no a lot of
things are easy to slide with whereas
back then it was very much like oh my
God and because it was Rihanna it kind
of made it worse I think
I feel like it's just because he's a guy
and there's like massive gender
inequality about it that's the only
reason I think yeah I think there's a
double standard where when men are
victims it doesn't really matter a
million percent yeah as many of you know
I was just banned on Tick Tock and we
are demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible